morning morning Chancellor day one of
his mission to rescue Liz truss's
Premiership and Jeremy Hunt began with
an admission there were mistakes it was
a mistake when we're going to be asking
for difficult decisions across the board
on tax and spending to cut the rate of
tax paid by the very wealthiest it was a
mistake to fly blind and to to do these
forecasts without giving people the
confidence of the office for Budget
responsibility saying that the sums add
up and the prime ministers recognize
that that's why I'm here in his first
interview as Chancellor he told Sky News
there could be more u-turns we're gonna
have to take some very tough decisions
on both spending and tax as I say
spending will not go up as much as
people want and there'll be more
efficiencies to find and we won't have
uh the speed of tax cuts we're hoping
for and some taxes will have to go up
that's the reality of the very
challenging situation we face
Mr Hunt spent his first day as
Chancellor here in the treasury being
briefed by officials on the enormous
economic challenges ahead on day two
he's off to Checkers for talks with the
Prime Minister as she battles to cling
to power and on day three Monday he'll
almost certainly have to face MPS in
Parliament
as Mr Hunt prepares with his officials
for his big Halloween statement on tax
and spending many conservative MPS will
be alarmed by a warning from the bank of
England Governor Andrew Bailey the
central Banker of the moment if I might
say
the governor says he's already spoken to
the new Chancellor and there could be a
bigger than expected interest rate rise
next month we will not hesitate to raise
interest rates to meet the inflation
Target and as things stand today my best
guess is that inflationary pressures
will require a stronger response than we
perhaps fought in August
that would further increase pressure on
the embattled Prime Minister
who some senior Tories are already
predicting will be gone before November
here he is but loyalist MPS claim that
by sacking quasi-quarting and bringing
in Mr Hunt the pm has at least bought
herself some time the chance has got to
look at
how we can bring the markets
along with us not do what we did
previously with the mini budget which
was disrupt the markets there's enough
disruption in in the Geo fiscal
political scene so we don't really want
it as the old saying goes flying the
horses the labor leader is accusing the
conservatives of putting party first and
Country second the grotesque chaos of a
Tory prime minister handing out
redundancy notices to our own Chancellor
must trust is this weekend plotting her
fight for survival at Checkers but
arguably Mr Hunt is now more powerful
than the prime minister
John Craig Sky News